Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
Tu parli veneziano.
E anche tu parli veneziano.
La verità è che tutti voi
parlate veneziano.
E non dico chi tra voi
sia nato, o viva, a Venezia:
intendo proprio tutti tutti.
Scrivete anche, in veneziano;
è che non lo sapete.
Questo perché Venezia ha finito
col diventare, nel corso della Storia,
una città ponte.
Ponte fra culture, fra persone,
fra saperi, cibi e consuetudini.
Al punto che alcune
fra queste consuetudini
sono divenute patrimonio del mondo intero,
sono divenute internazionali.
Ogni giorno, voi utilizzate qualcosa
che è stato inventato a Venezia:
oggetti, ma non solo.
Anche nell'esprimervi,
nel mandare un messaggio su WhatsApp,
nello scrivere un post su Instagram,
voi utilizzate qualcosa
che è nato a Venezia.
Ve ne faccio vedere un'immagine: eccola.
Riuscite a vederlo?
No, perché è a grandezza naturale.
Ora ve lo ripropongo,
ingrandito un milione di volte.
L'avete riconosciuto adesso, vero?
È il punto.
Il punto!
E con lui la virgola, l'accento,
l'apostrofo, il punto e virgola.
Così come sono in uso nella forma moderna,
sono stati utilizzati
per la prima volta a Venezia.
Dove non si inventa la stampa;
ma si perfeziona la punteggiatura,
che aiuta a scrivere e a leggere meglio.
D'altronde, "ponte" significa, anche,
prendere e trasformare,
ricreare e proporre, esportare.
A Venezia, dove nel corso del Cinquecento
si pubblica almeno la metà
dei libri stampati in tutta Europa
in quell'intero secolo,
viene inventato il corsivo,
che non a caso si chiama "Italic"
in tutti i computer del mondo.
Viene messo a punto il libro tascabile,
che diventa da quel momento
un oggetto trasportabile.
Tutto ciò si deve
al genio di Aldo Manuzio,
che non era veneziano
ma che a Venezia ebbe modo
di sperimentare e affermare
le sue intuizioni.
Perché Venezia fu così.
Ebbe la capacità di attrarre,
rimescolare, fondere
e far diventare veneziana
qualsiasi cosa potenzialmente innovativa
potesse accrescere le fortune dello Stato.
Non esiste una sola pietra della città
che non sia arrivata da un altrove.
È stato valido anche per le persone
nel corso della storia, in gran parte.
Di questa capacità di prendere il meglio,
e di farlo diventare veneziano,
abbiamo un meraviglioso esempio
in un documento che,
per la prima volta nella Storia,
parla esplicitamente
di protezione delle idee.
"Vi sono molti uomini",
si legge dal testo originale,
"di diverse origini.
Uomini con menti ingegnose in grado
di immaginare diversi oggetti artificiosi.
E se si facesse sì
che altri non possano riprodurre
le opere da essi inventate,
allora questi uomini
userebbero le loro menti
per scoprire cose di non poca utilità
per la nostra Repubblica."
Venezia inventa il brevetto:
lo fa il 19 marzo 1474.
Ma torniamo alle parole.
Quante volte,
nei giorni più cupi del COVID-19,
abbiamo pronunciato,
o sentito pronunciare,
le parole "Quarantena" o "Lazzaretto"?
Lazzaretto è invenzione
e parola veneziana.
Deriva dalla corruzione di "Nazaretum",
ovvero la chiesa
di Santa Maria di Nazareth
che sorgeva sulla prima isola della laguna
deputata a questo scopo, nel 1423:
il Lazzaretto Vecchio.
Qualche tempo dopo
fu istituito il Lazzaretto Nuovo,
con scopi di prevenzione
verso merci e persone
che venivano tenuti
in isolamento per 40 giorni.
La quarantena, inventata a Ragusa
dopo che per secoli
era stata possedimento veneziano,
e che i veneziani perfezionarono,
non è nient'altro
che "quarantina" in veneziano.
Quando dite "Quarantena", o "Lazzaretto",
parlate veneziano senza saperlo.
Anche la parola "Ghetto" nasce a Venezia,
assieme al primo ghetto della storia,
istituito nel 1516 per dare
ospitalità agli ebrei in città.
Non era un villaggio vacanze,
e le restrizioni erano significative;
ma non era nemmeno un luogo
di persecuzione o di tortura.
E la parola ghetto, che viene accolta
da molte lingue del mondo
e che è associata giustamente ai concetti
di separazione, sofferenza, enclave,
nasce in realtà innocentissima,
perché ne precede l'esistenza stessa.
In quel luogo, vi erano
delle antiche fonderie, "getti"
che ne avevano dato il nome,
e che i primi ebrei
ashkenaziti nordeuropei
trasformarono con una pronuncia più dura.
Quando dite "Ghetto" parlate veneziano,
e forse non lo sapete.
Lo fate anche quando dite "Arsenale".
Quella di Venezia fu la prima vera
catena di montaggio della storia,
capace di varare navi
a una velocità impressionante,
al punto da entrare
nel lessico comune di molte lingue.
Gli anglofoni sembrano, anzi, essere
fra i più fedeli riproduttori
di parole veneziane:
ma non solo di quelle,
anche di altre cose.
Come l'architettura
di Andrea Palladio, per esempio.
Venezia peraltro inventa -
e Andrea Palladio
ne è uno dei massimi artefici -
la "Civiltà di villa": la villeggiatura.
Quando fate la villeggiatura,
fate qualcosa di molto veneziano.
A Venezia si suppone
siano stati inventati gli occhiali,
e con certezza viene inventato
lo specchio, nel 1540.
È una data spartiacque:
prima di quel momento,
venivano utilizzati dei metalli lucidati
o dei vetri grezzi,
che restituivano un'immagine poco fedele.
Da quel momento in poi, ognuno fu in grado
di vedere se stesso così com'era,
e la percezione di sé
cambiò radicalmente e per sempre.
Quando vi guardate allo specchio,
ogni mattina che Dio manda in terra,
e assonnati rimirate la vostra immagine,
in realtà state ammirando
una invenzione veneziana.
Venezia inventa un sistema elettorale.
Lo mette a fin prima del mille, lo affina,
lo fa diventare
pressoché definitivo nel 1297.
E quando due fra le democrazie
più antiche della storia moderna,
quella statunitense e quella francese,
compiute le rispettive rivoluzioni
decidono di dotarsi
di un sistema elettorale,
dove credete che lo vadano a pescare?
Vengono a Venezia, e studiano
quello in uso da secoli.
Ancor oggi, in Francia,
è invalso l'uso del "ballottage".
Nei paesi anglofoni, l'urna elettorale
si chiama "Ballot box".
Entrambe retaggio dell'utilizzo
di ballotte, "baeote",
con le quali i veneziani
eleggevano il doge,
e le altre Magistrature dello Stato.
Potrei continuare narrandovi
di come Venezia apra al mondo
la prima casa da gioco pubblica, nel 1638:
il "Ridotto Grande".
Un anno prima,
aveva avuto luogo
una rappresentazione musicale
in un teatro, il San Cassiano,
alla quale era stato ammesso,
per la prima volta nella Storia,
un pubblico pagante.
E questo utilizzo del biglietto,
apparentemente così semplice,
sconvolge invece per sempre
i canoni della composizione.
Invece, mi limiterò
a salutarvi con un "Ciao".
Un saluto semplice, diretto, bello,
e ormai usato in molti luoghi della terra.
Ebbene, è veneziano:
quando dite "ciao", parlate
come i veneziani di qualche secolo fa.
"Ciao" non è nient'altro
che la contrazione di "schiavo vostro",
forma ossequiosa di saluto
molto in voga ai tempi della Serenissima.
Quando dite "ciao" a qualcuno,
vi dichiarate suo schiavo.
Attenzione: non è una forma
di sottomissione, è un ossequio.
L'altra persona non vi sta
costringendo a fare nulla.
Siete voi che, serenamente,
vi mettete al suo servizio.
Non c'è violenza, nel ciao.
D'altronde Venezia è, formalmente,
la prima nazione al mondo
che abolisce la schiavitù
in un documento ufficiale nel 960 -
avete sentito bene: 960.
L'ultima a farlo fu
la Mauritania, nel 1980:
1020 anni più tardi.
Ciò non significa che i veneziani
non abbiano avuto degli schiavi,
o non ne abbiano commerciati
nel corso della Storia.
I veneziani hanno, anche,
una bellissima bandiera,
che è fra le più antiche
ancora esistenti, e tuttora in utilizzo.
Ed è anche l'unico vessillo
di uno Stato nazionale
sul quale compaia la parola "Pace".
Anche questo è curioso,
per un popolo che fu
bravissimo a fare la guerra
e che inventò e montò per primo,
ingegneristicamente,
i cannoni laterali sulle sue navi.
Fa tutto parte delle contraddizioni
di un grande popolo con una lunga storia.
Ma tutto si tiene.
Pace.
Schiavo vostro.
Sciavo.
Ciao.
(Applausi)